Chace Stokes breaks his silence issuing
an apology for some old quote
insensitive posts on social media domino
effect so are you responsible for your
actions here's what went down a Twitter
user recently uploaded a few screenshots
of old now deleted posts from the Outer
Banks stars social media accounts some
of the 27 year olds posts included
racial slurs and derogatory terms
towards people with disabilities and
people who are a part of the lgbtq+
communities one tweet even referenced
Justin Bieber well that kicked off some
major online backlash and on Monday the
Netflix star wrote an apology to anyone
he may have heard in the statement
posted to Twitter Chase explained that
he took a beat to consult a friend over
how to handle the whole thing he took
responsibility for his actions writing
that he has posted insensitive tweets in
the past but he also said his Facebook
had been hacked countless times huh I
don't talk about this he wrote quote I
am incredibly sorry I really am I hope
you guys see what I am currently doing
and how I am continuing to do the right
thing by being respectful in today's
climate and he wrapped it all up by
acknowledging that his apology doesn't
erase his past actions this does not
excuse my words nor am i excusing myself
well just moments after Chase tweeted
his apology he claimed he got hacked on
Twitter not only was his statement
erased but all of his past tweets were -
like all of them on Monday night chase
explained the whole thing tweeting that
someone got access to his account and
his password had been changed quote I'm
really sorry that this is all happening
at once this is what we call a hot mess
Express folks eg caught up with Chase
and his co-star Maddy Klein in April
right before Outer Banks dropped on
Netflix and he opened up about preparing
for fames
the DMS have started people started to
kind of reach
we're seeing a little bit of things
happening on online but the super
instead I mean it's really cool you know
to obviously see people attached to
something when it's not even out like to
have people saying things about the show
and about the trailer in itself and to
see that without them having any
substance yet I think it's exciting I
mean I think it's cool to give people
some sort of hope and I think this show
does a really good job
[Music]